ils sont les représentants des
collectivités territoriales le président
du sénat gérard larcher ainsi que les
sénateurs les républicains des yvelines
effectué des visites auprès des élus
locaux et les visites que toute l'équipe
nous faisons les cinq sénateur des
yvelines avec leurs suppléants et nous
consacrons à peu près toutes les cinq
semaines
une journée à sur le territoire bien sûr
à la rencontre des élus mais aussi à la
rencontre des réalisations et de la vie
des territoires
vendredi 8 mars le maire de versailles
leur a montré les avancées de son projet
de réhabilitation du quartier de la gare
des chantiers c'est très important pour
nous d'abord parce que c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes nous les élus
défendent essentiellement par le sénat
le sénat c'est l'assemblée qui
représente les élus territoriaux et
particulièrement les mères est
aujourd'hui est important qui est cette
voix qui soit posée au niveau national
parce que dans ces grands problèmes du
moment on sent bien que la solidité de
notre nation elle tient à la présence de
tous ces élus et notamment je pense
aussi des élus municipaux nouveau siège
de nature et découverte et visite des
bâtiments de nexity et déplacements à
travers le jardin des étangs gaubert la
ville de versailles a présenté son
concept de ville nature et ses
réalisations en cours c'est aussi une
des manières de valoriser le bien
prochaine visite au planning pour les
sénateurs yvelinois au sein des communes
de l'agglomération versailles grand parc